Es ist ein wirklich wahnsinns schritt für die astrophysik die bisher
verborgenen materie wurde gefunden die wissenschaft weiß ja ziemlich
Genau wie sich materie dunkle materie und dunkle energie umwelt verteilen
Noch immer ist sie auf der suche nach der dunkle materie und kann sie einfach nicht finden
Genauso wie die dunkle energie doch auch die materie wie wir sie kennen ist nur schwer auffindbar insgesamt die hälfte
der materie war bisher nicht auf hinweis- und
Das ist jetzt anders die fehlenden 50
Prozent wurden aufgespürt wie das gelang und wo sich diese materie befindet jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja das universum ist schon ein
Mysterium das wir wirklich nur sehr ungenau kennen nicht nur dass wir keine ahnung von
Dunkler materie und dunkler energie haben wir haben nicht den blassesten schimmer ob sie wirklich existieren und wo sie sind und aus was sie
bestehen wir wissen lediglich
27 prozent des universums bestehen aus dunkler materie und 68 prozent sind dunkle energie wobei wir haben
gravitationslinsen beobachtet die durch die dunkle materie
Verursacht werden also die umlenkung des lichts durch dunkle materie aber sie selbst die haben wir noch
Nie gesehen gemessen oder haben die teilchen entdeckt
Aus der sie bestehen könnte ja ist ja auch schwierig sehr heiß her schließlich dunkel aber auch die materie die wir kennen war bisher
zur hälfte einfach nicht auffindbar bzw konnte nicht nachgewiesen werden
Also die restlichen 5 denn was wir säen sterne nebel
Planeten galaxien das macht nur einen bruchteil der bekannten materie aus es ist ein zehntel also
0,5 prozent des universums weitere 40 prozent
Konnten bisher als gas zwischen den galaxien gefunden werden die galaxien sind so weit voneinander entfernt dass selbst die wenigen
teilchen zwischen ihnen
unglaubliche mengen ausmachen und jetzt wurde auch der rest der zwischen den galaxien als dünne gas fäden existiert
aufgespürt die verborgene materie zwar forschungsteams kamen daher unabhängig voneinander auf dieselbe idee sie werteten daten
des blank satelliten nach temperaturdaten aus durchfliegen photonen also lichtteilchen
solche heißen gaswolken verringert sich die zahl der niedrigenergie ethischen photonen und die der höhe
energetischen photonen erhöht sich da wo sich also das verhältnis dieser lichtteilchen
Relativ zur hintergrundstrahlung verändert dort gibt es gas zusammen haben die forschungsgruppen diese gas filamente
also
diese gas fehden zwischen mehr als einer millionen galaxien untersucht und dabei
Konnten sie durch die erhobenen daten auf die menge des gases zurück schließen und bäm
Es entspricht exakt der menge der materie die wir bisher noch nicht gefunden hatten jetzt kam zum ersten mal eine wirklich ex
Akte karte des universums
Angefertigt werden denn erst jetzt wissen wir wo sich die bekannte material befindet allerdings wird diese karte eine große lücke haben
Wo die restlichen 95 prozent. Also die dunkle energie und die dunkle materie sind das wissen wir nicht
Wo ja wenn es mehr erkenntnisse dazu gibt der vater ist natürlich hier bei pixum wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen
Themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke ja hier geht s
Zu dunkle materie rätsel wie wild spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle da geht es um die wirklich sehr sehr spannende these
Dass die dunkle materie will ich gar nicht so unbekannt ist extrem spannend also ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran